how's Gomes - pure a zebras no I swear
way too much in my [ __ ] videos so I
got this a pet collar electric thing to
train myself we're gonna play the
impossible game if I swear I will have
to zap myself so every time I do it I
will up it by five at least cuz I don't
want to kill myself
alright here we go fantastic
so I older to play geometry dash which
is I don't know which one nothing
I don't know which one copied which one
med I think this one is the first one
like I say I'm gonna clear this map on
the first try don't even don't even even
me look at this [ __ ] mut nut goddamn can
I say like what can I say you here what
what Kansas is swear knowing how dumb my
brain is I'm gonna forget in a second so
you have to watch out from swearing and
dying now it's not easy mad oh come on
what the hell satisfier word okay they
said no come on every time what the hell
is that
come on yes Oh make it I'm the bassist
it's gonna be a tricky one soon isn't it
oh my god
goddamn that's too hard for me man never
gonna be able to do that one the
framerate is killing my eyes when he
says shitty port man why is shitty up
swearing
I got dammit alright people are saying
it's a swear word whatever I'm a man I
don't give a [ __ ] oh god yeah how tight
should this be it's on five oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh no oh hell no that was fine
it goes to a hand rid okay I'm not gonna
swear I'm not gonna swear i toughed
don't say anything bad
what is he doing stop jumping do you
little
ah Jesus mother of fine-ass [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] come on
ha ha I'll use it on my arm okay here
here we go ten I'll tell anything well
apparently I became a man it's weird
why did I feel fine but not ten okay
here we go come on baby man leading job
but I didn't say anything
come on Dean you little wonderful nice
little guy I love you here we go baby
come on you what the hell am I supposed
to do bending jab nothing
Mindy oh Jesus come on baby girl oh oh
oh oh oh what the [ __ ]
fifteen
come on Minnie jab Jesus there's
something wrong with me man 20 Oh God
uh-oh
ah oh I burned so good oh I felt so good
let's do that again many fun oh my god
oh my god I'm so stupid
seriously oh god 2000 damn oh damn who's
the pro hey that's me baby gay how long
are you gonna do this what the finest
nice persons in my face whoa what the
hell with yeah I can say that yeah just
come [ __ ]
that's how we do it in the put shut up
can I say that I can say that right oh
my god have to place so much to come
back man oh god oh god oh god I'm so
lucky there don't make it wasted pits oh
come on
my ninja blah pani Hellmuth this
Chandler early I'll do this one on my
leg I was gonna hurt oh I'm a little
less pain on the leg actually I think
it's cuz I'm more fat there
there we go baby there we go baby
that's how we do it in the pool pot
pound girl bring it on baby I said baby
timbala Jonathan Jana
oh man Dean man helmet is far helmet I'm
gonna do it on my lips that's a bad idea
through the leg again leg didn't hurt as
much 35 I don't want to talk to Oh saw
Donnie big does Jeff know more no oh God
here we go baby girl come on oh I hate
this game with a passion why would they
make this why why is he orange orange is
the devil did Kevin all right there we
go
huh huh here we go baby go aah
Oh
yes I can feel that bring it Britany god
I don't like this triple jump come on
ooh bring in that funny yeah Oh
ah I'll do my other leg now because my
other leg is fried this is gonna suck oh
oh media Jesus [ __ ] dick stains in a
penis [ __ ] a [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
licking mother [ __ ] hate this triple
triple triple triple triple drop over
gamma okay hey guys pulling why are you
guys watching you do why did you give I
mean fine ass [ __ ] oh my god fine ass
[ __ ] really fine ass [ __ ]
good job me fortify it love this it's my
favorite part of life
I'm such a [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god I don't
want to swear any boy I'm so sorry
everyone I don't have never do it again
I will never do it again I'm so sorry
I'm so so sorry
oh my god oh my fine eyes God as is all
why what is it yeah it isn't
I hope um come on
big fine head with this job Lafitte they
all that I job life are these kinks
copper spoiler helmet does Chaplin
bundler Jesus alright hope you enjoy
scepters live like we did is it scary
from today I'm never gonna do this
[ __ ] [ __ ] again there was a dumb ass
[ __ ] idea and I'll see you
tomorrow love you but stay awesome